[Musique]
le vendredi 3 mai 2010 9,7 pouces
j'aurais grise est partout au canada
quant à montréal qu'à toronto on attend
de la pluie au canada vancouver par
exemple ou à moncton et bien c'est gris
mais par contre c'est pas de pluie c'est
un temps agréable dans la quelle belle
image du canada et monsieur bonjour
bienvenue at entame une émission très
très intéressante je peut applaudir avec
une belle brochette d'invités
alors aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale de la liberté de presse
donc évidemment parlera de ça mais avant
de dire les plus loin je vais vous
présenter mes invités aujourd'hui mes
collaborateurs et monde et marteau de
radio canada international on joue
vraiment on à la boucherie boucherie
pratique de radio canada
bonjour reporter qui s'intéresse
beaucoup aux nouvelles technologies en
particulier aux fausses nouvelles pascal
lapointe fille et rédacteur en chef de
l'agencé science presse un moyen bon
jour et puis à mais le mail qui l
architecte urbaniste qui s'intéresse
entre autres choses aux questions
d'aménagement et ça tombe très bien
parce que on parlera de cette nouvelle a
qui n'est pas une fausse nouvelle pour
commencer parce qu'on parle de fausse
nouvelle meilleure nouvelle qui est
vraiment une nouvelle qui
malheureusement près que beaucoup de
gens en ce moment et bien voilà une idée
de ce qui se passe depuis quelques jours
dans l'est du canada
toutes arrachées ou presque la moitié
des murs les planchers au complet le bas
de la cuisine on récupère ce qu'on est
capable de récupérer mais y'a pas grand
chose à récupérer
l'ampleur des dégâts surprend les
habitués des crues printanières de la
rivière chaudière ce qu'ils vivent c'est
du jamais vu
j'ai tout vécu 2006 2014 2017
j'ai jamais jamais jamais eu une goutte
sur le plancher jamais qu'il eut reconnu
au comptoir de cuisine mais les
beaucerons se retrousse les manches plus
de 205 d'un reportage de pierre
alexandre bolduc que ça sa sainte marie
de brousse alors donc depuis à peu près
trois semaines dans l'est du canada
c'est-à-dire au québec au nouveau
brunswick et en ontario
il ya des crues printanières il ya plus
de dix mille personnes qui ont été
déplacées
les dégâts matériels sont innombrables
alors évidemment dame nature un pas
l'origine de tout ça mais espère que
dame nature qu'il faut blâmer dans ce
qui se passe en ce moment ma n'est
jamais le bon jour
bonjour alors modèle est ce qu'au fond
il faut simplement s'en prendre à dame
nature dans ce qui se passe en ce moment
je ne pense pas je ne pense pas parce
que c'est vrai que dame nature
elle était là beaucoup longtemps avant
nous il commençait juste que l'action
humaine elle s'est un peu intensifiées
durant les dernières durant dix ans le
dernier siècle
en fait depuis pr peut-être les années
1800 fin des années 1800 où l'homme il a
commencé à s'imaginer plus fort avec la
révolution industrielle à pouvoir
maîtriser et dompter cette cette bête
mais on voit toujours qu'il ya un retour
cyclique
ça veut dire les tempêtes les cyclones
les inondations c'est vrai que ça se
calme à un moment puis ça revient
mais pendant la dernière décennie on
voit une intensification de ces
événements extrêmes est ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui au canada est extrême
la classification des inondations se
fait généralement par le pourcentage de
probabilité d'avoir une inondation à
chaque année chose que la majorité du
citoyen normal le monsieur madame tout
le monde ne saisissent pas beaucoup
parce que la zone 0 20 ans et la zone 0
20 cent ans ça ne veut pas dire que tu
vas être inondées au 20 ans ou au centre
ça veut dire que tu vas avoir 5 % de
probabilité de chances d'être inondés
situé dans la zone 0,20 et 1,1 pour cent
de probabilités de champs situés dans la
zone sans chose qui était un peu changé
ces derniers temps parce qu'on a eu deux
inondations successives 2017 2019
en l'espace de deux ans ce qui est
exceptionnel donc les scientifiques ne
sont pas encore d'accord sur le fait que
ça soit le résultat des changements
climatiques parce que c'est vrai qu'il
ya des sonnettes d'alarmé peu partout le
15 mars on a vu la marche des étudiants
les scientifiques en parle mais il ya
plusieurs facteurs
il ya plusieurs facteurs entre autres
l'urbanisation extrême justement c'est
ce que je voulais aborder comme comme
sujet qu est ce qu on a fait mal ou
qu'est-ce qu'on ne fait pas bien
qu'est-ce qu'on sent pas compris du
point de vue de l'urbanisation de
l'aménagement du territoire en fait les
leçons apprises non pas ne sont pas
encore déjà sorti ça veut dire on
travaille encore là dessus on travaille
encore vous savez touchant de sciences
touchant scientifique et est consciente
et vos critiques wii est en constante
critiques c'est à dire toujours on se
remet en question en architecture on se
remet en question est ce qu'on fait bon
est ce qu'on construit bon aujourd'hui
on commence à s'orienter plus vers des
constructions en bois parce que c'est
mieux c'est plus écologique peut-être
parce que est entre autres moi je dis
c'est un retour parce qu'ici au canada à
la base on construisait en bois puis
après avec l'avènement du btan avec
diane et hop le béton c'est mieux au
niveau de la l'urbanisation des dérives
de l'occupation du territoire au bord
des fleuves et des rives
au début c'était une occupation
saisonnière avant les canadiens allaient
passer leur été au bord de l'eau donc
c'est des installations qui à la base
était des chalets étaient des
installations saisonnière entre
guillemets légère de point de vue
structures qui sont petit à petit évolué
en maison de d'installations permanentes
et pour stabiliser et rendre ce bâtiment
plus forts dont la fortifier lui l'ami
du béton pour le rendre lourd et selon
moi et ça c'est ma propre perception je
trouve que la nature n'a pas accepté
cette agression parce que quand le
bâtiment il est assez léger il est en
bois c'est quand même c'est quand même
naturel le bâtiment il peut un peu agir
avec l'environnement mais quand on
installe des fondations profondes
embêtant l'eau des rivières il a besoin
de respirer il a besoin de soins tu es
un peu partout c'est comme des petites
branches et puis là on vient installer
un une fondation en béton dont chloé la
petite la petite faute d'eau qui a
l'habitude de passer et ce bloc puis
qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle augmente le
niveau d'eau de la rivière puis la
rivière elle embarque sur les sur les
bords on a pris beaucoup de place qui
était de la place allô oui
au fil des années et je dirais surtout
depuis depuis la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale puis 45 50 a maintenant
et la place au bord de l'eau est un
espace immobilier valence ont presque
pesant d'or oui et c'est une source
c'est nominale de revenus pour une
municipalité
ça c'est indéniable donc à ce moment là
on quitte la zone écologique quand on
dans la zone politique et financière
justement en fait tout dépend du point
de vue de l'analyse avec laquelle on
peut observer le phénomène
ce phénomène là si on le tient au centre
et on essaie de le voir des différents
points de vue on va pas se rejoindre
parce que c'est vrai que premièrement
l'être humain il veut il vise son
bien-être
philosophiquement parlant en vie pour
être bien donc le bien-être c'est
l'occupation des jeunes qui sont les
plus belles
les paysages les naturelles donc du coup
le citoyen s'est installée étant donné
cette valeur là la valeur du bâtiment
dans cette zone là ils elles augmentent
elles augmentent puis là elle ajoute une
valeur financière et une assiette fixa
fiscale pardon municipal assez
intéressante
donc oui c'est un gain et cesser le
trésor des municipalités qui ont des
cours d'eau qui ont des fleuves par
contre si on va prendre les lunettes de
quelqu'un qui se soucie de la nature et
de l'environnement
on va voir que c'est une agression à la
nature donc le juste milieu est vrai
aujourd'hui c'est au coeur du débat
comment ne pas nuire à la municipalité
et le pas nuire à leur fiscalité parce
que à la base des municipalités
souffrent parce qu'ils ont des besoins
énormes mais elles n'arrivent pas à
trouver leurs ressources financières
quelque part mais en même temps aussi la
nature souffre et la souffrance ça c'est
mon avis personnel la souffrance d'une
institution on peut la réparer mais la
souffrance de la magie de la nature
elle est dommageable sur toute
l'humanité ne sélectionnent personne
parce que si on peut viser une
municipalité de 3 15 25
tout dépend du territoire qui est à
risque d'inondation
mais quand l'ol va monter vous avez vu
ça n'a épargné personne
illzach et danser dans ce contexte là
que pensez-vous de la suggestion du
premier ministre français logo de
déménager des gens de relocaliser les
gens qui habitent dans certaines zones à
risque c'est très c'est très intéressant
et ça c'est ce que toute la communauté
scientifique n'arrête pas de le dire
c'est que si tu habites une zone à
risque le mieux pour toi pour ta
sécurité c'est de la quitter c'est de
sacrifier ce besoin de pia naître pour
ta sécurité principal on vient de voir
dans le reportage les dégâts matériels
mais au delà des dégâts matériels il ya
des dégâts psychologiques
on y moi j'ai trois mois je travaille
pour ce qu'on appelle un bureau de
rétablissement des inondations qu'a été
mis en place par la municipalité de
rigaud pour gérer le rétablissement des
îles des personnes sinistrées et des à
suite aux inondations 2017 en gère
jusqu'à aujourd'hui des détresses
psychologiques des
en d2 2017 donc ça fait deux ans et ça
n'a pas été donc la résilience elle est
un peu lente vis-à-vis d'un sinistre les
gens vivent une situation vraiment de
stress post traumatique un stress post
traumatique rajouter avec une autre
situation d'urgence
c'est moi je suis vraiment de tout coeur
avec ces gens là parce que c'est
traumatisant pour e.on et des citadins
on est des gens qui en résident et puis
on s'accroche à notre environnement
d'une maison les photos de famille on
voit souvent dans les une madame qui
était en détresse elle est venue
chercher les albums photos de ses
enfants
c'est vrai on s'accroche oui on
s'accroche au matériel mais ça c'est ce
qui nous rassure l'être humain il a
besoin d'être rassuré moi je suis
rassurée avec mon cahier voyez donc se
détresser donc mais on comprend aussi la
préoccupation du gouvernement
legault ou de tout autre gouvernement
parce que c'est aussi une action
politique très dangereuse très délicate
très délicate
c'est à dire comment être pour et avec
les citoyens mais aussi pour et avec un
environnement que c'est lui qui est plus
durable
donc je salue leur courage
mais il faut être je les encourage aussi
à être encore plus courageux si je vous
posais la question suivante se serait de
d'aller chercher une expertise à
l'international de gens qui vivent avec
cette notion de systématiquement je
pense aux pays bas qui est aussi surtout
à la ville de nimègue timing la ville
qui a redonné à l'eau son espace vital
le parc existe sept à huit mois par
année neuf mois les trois autres c'est
une zone inondable et ça c'est un
exemple l'exemple également aussi des
des fameuses digue
quand vous roulez aux pays bas et vous
montez par exemple vous passez d'un
champ un autre entre les deux vous avez
une digue de deux mains deux mètres et
demi mais entre les deux il ya cours
d'eau ça c'est des gens qui connaissent
et qu'ils vivent et qui ont une
expertise profonde en la matière est ce
que on tape sur des épaules
là bas
en fait le pays boos est un pays qui
dans 60 % du territoire et en bas du
niveau de la mer dans presque tout le
pays vit en bas du niveau
d'après ma petite recherche parce que je
commence aussi à travailler sur ça ils
ont trouvé un processus assez complexe
et compliquée et assez complet en fait
c'est à dire d'arrimer et l'aménagement
du territoire et l'occupation de
l'espace parce que pour eux ces
territoires ne sont pas uniquement
urbains ils sont aussi agricole c'est
des terrains de pâturage donc
premièrement on n'a pas cette
problématique là de fondation et tout ça
ça c'est en premier parce que j'ai vu
c'est des étendues de terres de pâturage
deuxièmement au niveau de la fiscalité
il ya eu comme un mouvement citoyen de
tout le pays et ça peut être aussi en
tant que nation on doit être solidaire
tout le monde pour dire ok on a des on a
des hall dangereuse on a des zones à
risque
on a des zones de vulnérabilité naturel
il faut que tout le monde cotise il faut
que tout le monde aide c'est à dire
c'est pas moi j'habite loin je me dis
mangement fou lui il a choisi d'habiter
au bord de l'eau c'est sans la faire il
va assumer sa responsabilité non c'est
une responsabilité collective on ait un
seul pays on est tous ensemble donc eux
qu'est ce qu'ils font les citoyens ils
paient comme une petite taxe pour aider
le gouvernement à lutter contre les ces
risques là c'est une taxe je pense qui
s'élève aux alentours de 90 euros je
pense par famille je ne suis pas certain
du chiffre oui c'est à 120 dollars par
année je pense que c'est pas énorme
c'est vrai que pour certains mais ça
c'est peut-être pour les maisons qui
sont pour les gens qui ceux qui paient
des taxes municipales donc c'est au
niveau des municipales je ne suis pas
experte dans le domaine de l'économie
mais je pense que le comité
interministériel qui est qui a été mis
sur place ce qui a été annoncé par
monsieur legault je pense que il vise ça
c'est que tous les ministres chacun il
va apporter son point de vue parce que
comme on a dit c'est pas un problème de
nature uniquement ce peintre de problème
territorial uniquement c'est aussi un
problème fiscal c'est un problème de
revenus c'est aussi un problème de
capacité du gouvernement
à offrir cette infrastructure routière
cette infrastructure de digues et de
barrages ces digues et barrages sont des
installations énorme et il nécessite un
entretien majeurs c'est à dire on
construit pas eu 10 gants la laisse il
faut la check est tout le temps il faut
la vérifier il faut faire des
vérifications
il faut mettre une équipe d'ingénieurs
dédié à ça est-ce qu'on a les moyens
voilà dernière question djamel
intelligente au début de votre notre
notre échange sur la télévision comme
matériau matériaux de construction est
ce que le fait d'utiliser parlant
d'egypte rocks au lieu de ça pas les
parcs pendant six mois est-ce que ça
aussi ça ne complique pas les choses
parce qu'il ya des maisons qu'on a vu à
dans le reportage qui sont détruites qui
sont irrécupérables à cause du matériel
le matériel cette pratique pour des
raisons climatiques et tours
c'est peut-être ça c'est le pôle
isolation l'hiver mais par la suite si
un dégât d'eau ça devient un problème
est ce qu'au niveau de la recherche au
niveau de votre niveau est ce que c'est
une réflexion qu'on peut qu'on peut
entreprendre aussi bon je sais pas moi
depuis l'observation qu'on a fait c'est
que oui les dégâts matériels sont
énormes c'est vrai que les maisons qui
ont été construites en bois ont reçu
moins de dégâts ce à dire quand parce
que moi je travaille pour une firme
privée qui s'appelle un frappe
planification urbaine et qui offre les
services d'inspecteurs pour les
municipalités
donc lorsqu'on inspectent c'est vrai que
les bâtiments qui sont construits en
bois ont reçu moins de dommages que le
gie broc qui s'effrite avec l'eau et
tout ça sauf que là mais la méthode de
construction elle est là ça va on va
ouvrir un chantier énorme micro mais
c'est un chantier de formation de nos de
notre main-d'oeuvre grande de
construction de nos entrepreneurs
c'est à dire c'est toute une culture
constructive quitter sainte qui s'est
installé au canada et au québec
donc c'est une culture constructive
c'est vrai qu'avec les chaires de
recherche
on essaie de travailler pour réfléchir à
ça mais il n'y a pas de réponse magique
il n'y a pas de solution n'est pas de
recette moi personnellement mon message
c'est il faut s'adapter
et puis il faut accepter que on n'occupe
pas ces territoires là et en
urbaniser dans d'autres zones
on doit densifier moi j'appelle beaucoup
à la densification
on a beaucoup d'étalement urbain autour
de l'eau ville donc la densification et
la création de pôles urbains
c'est vrai que les ordres professionnels
que ce soit à l'ordre des architectes
l'ordre des urbanistes travaille
activement sur la mise en place de ces
plans là comment offrir aux citoyens un
meilleur bien-être tout en étant en
cohérence avec l'environnement voilà j
mais je rappelle que vous êtes
urbanistes architectes et entre autres
choses chargé de couvrir agir en
urbanisme pas encore senti très dur des
surpiqûres humaniste en tout cas je
pense que vous seriez une bonne
urbanistes celui-ci en juger par pas vos
connaissances donc merci beaucoup je
pensais que ces inventions
merci ça se passe l'examen en 2016 six
mois avant l'élection de nature
d'un côté de la rue des gens sont venus
manifester à l'invitation d'un groupe
facebook offre existe ils protestent
contre ce qu'ils appellent une
islamisation du texas
et de l'autre côté de la rue des
contre-manifestants
mobilisés par une autre page facebook
your mother of america une vraie manif
dans les rues de houston complètement
organisé par des comptes facebook en
russie et ont quand même réussi à
mobiliser des gens pour aller dans les
rues faire partager les événements
facebook sur les réseaux sociaux des
gens ce soir gino harel et luc tremblay
nous amène dans le monde du faux et de
la désinformation
voilà donc les fausses nouvelles les
postes nouvelle c'est nous sommes dans
cette époque là dans ces terres là elles
ont toujours existé semble-t-il mais
avec les outils dont on dispose
aujourd'hui ça attentivement beaucoup
plus plus plus fort et malheureusement
des conséquences aussi parfois qui
peuvent être désastreuses
d'abord premier tour de table est ce que
tu es que parmi vous ici à des gens qui
ont mordu à l'hameçon des fausses
nouvelles oui oui un exemple de fausses
nouvelles abondance ça me coûtait des
joues oui carrément une arnaque que la
nacam fait royalement prendre bêtement
quoi je travaille dans ce milieu si
depuis plus d'une quarantaine d'années
est malgré tout je me suis fait prendre
avec une passe du genre je peux en rire
aujourd'hui on n'est pas que non c'était
pedro c'est a carrément écoute on s'en
va vous saisir s'il faut payer
j'ai pas payer 6000 à l'armée j'ai fait
quelques cheveux alors bouchra wathiq
vous êtes journaliste vous traquer les
nouvelles sur le web
oui ce que vous êtes aussi vous avez
aussi bien là me sont générés depuis
quelques années je suis devenu très
sceptique très méfiante mais
bon comme tout le monde sait que ce
phénomène que beaucoup évolué mais
maintenant comme on l'a vu dans les
traits du reportage j'ai vraiment des
gens mal intentionnés qui vont créer des
fausses et des fausses articles ont en
tous points leur vrai mais avant ces
quelques années la mode c'était plutôt
les articles s'assurer que des diagne n
qui très connu aux états unis qui fait
des articles sont faits pour être un peu
drôle c'est clairement identifié que le
site et 7 ciric
mais quand on le connaît papillon il y
eu au québec le journal de montréal donc
il ya une réussite de mourir l'homme on
n'est plus passé dans l'ère des forces
nouvelles qui veulent en tout point à
être vrai mais quelques années la grosse
manne stelly site satirique
c'est arrivé dès fois que je sache pas
du premier coup que c'est laid satirique
mai dont une fois qu'on se fait prendre
à faire on s'est donc je pense que c'est
impossible d'être totalement immunisé
contre les les forces nouvelles contre
les faux article je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de deux jeunes à avoir ou demande à
voir le dire bobines fois j'ai partagé
quelque chose puis finalement on me dit
sûr que cet article est vrai et puis les
facile ça peut arriver à n'importe qui
c'est comme question de deux poètes y
discute quoi que ce soit mais je pense
que justement faut accepter que ça peut
tous nous arriver puis de développer un
peu un sixième sens voudrait que là
quand je vois un article alors un peu
douteuse je vire fille vraiment c'est
quoi c'est quoi ce site le doubien ce
que c'est un vrai média mais mes cd
réflexe qu'on acquiert avec l'état mais
pascal vous le scientifique du groupe
ici avant ses skis ça vous arrive et de
mordre à l'hameçon belge qu'on ne
bouchera et lucien c'est que moi parce
que l'information de sciences venez pas
mais je ne peux que d'enchérir ce
qu'elles viennent dire effectivement au
fil des années on développe des réflexes
comme on les journalistes pour être plus
sceptiques et bombay le phénomène des
fausses nouvelles le fait qu'une partie
de mon travail consistait depuis ces
dernières années et essayez d'imaginer
quelle stratégie pourrait transmettre à
d'autres personnes pour éviter de tomber
dans le panneau
alors moi même je sais de mettre en
pratique
bouchra senti la chose la plus
importante à retenir de l'émission
aujourd'hui c'est que tout le monde peut
tomber dans le panneau
il faut à aucun prix transmettre l'idée
qu'une personne qui a partagé une fausse
nouvelle dans votre entourage est idiote
c'est laisser couper la communication de
façon sûre il faut que tout trouvé des
trucs par lesquels on peut lui apprendre
subtilement mais regarde fait ainsi de
s'attirer c'est une limace une nouvelle
de 2012
est ce qu'une étude derrière ça mais
c'est de suite ce qui est dommage à
travers ça c'est comme comment voyez le
reportage c'est qu'il ya des gens qui
sont montés en colère et en violence par
quelque chose qui était fonctionnement
clanique et ailleurs il voit là qu'est
ce ça fait mais c'est ça la clé des
fausses nouvelles si la fausse nouvelle
était totalement absurde invraisemblable
personne n'y croirait alors elle est
faite sur mesure pour que les gens ou
dans cette école où un groupe précis
comme celui combien de voix ils croient
non à l'hameçon ça nous arrivait aussi
avons pas personnellement mais je vais
rester dans le cadre des inondations
dans le temps mais c'est vrai parce que
c'est quand des sites les sinistrés sont
en situation de détresse
l'information passe vite et la fausse
nouvelle a une oreille plus grandes
chanteuses d'accord donc là c'est notre
rôle c'est le rôle des institutions à
écouter les gens il a dit attendez c'est
pas ça l'information oui mais parce que
j'ai écouté mon voisin qui disent non
écoute pas ton voisin t qui t'écoutent
le responsable tu regardes là parce que
la même aujourd'hui on vient nous dire
ouais mais parce que le nouveau
gouvernement elle a changé la procédure
on n'a pas encore commencé leur
établissement on est encore en train de
gérer le sinistre on est encore en train
de sécuriser les gens chez eux et alex
est allé à les mettre à l'abri
donc on n'a pas encore commencé et les
nouvelles autour de compensation
combien on va payer quand bien je peux
me récupère et tout ça c'est oui la
fausse nouvelle
aj beaucoup dans ce domaine est la
fausse nouvelle agit selon moi sur des
personnes vulnérables se soient
vulnérables psychologiquement ou
vulnérables c'est-à-dire des jeunes des
mêmes blessures j'ai été souvent là sur
facebook c'est comme un peu mourial mais
il ya une page facebook qui s'appelle
leurs tresses bas la presse mais leur
presse et parfois je tombe sur un
article choc et puis après je vais rien
ne nous est pas la presse ensuite tout
savoir moi aussi je me suis fait avoir
par cela c'est un poisson d'avril qui
annonçait que membre d'un groupe très
connu que vous connaissez d'ailleurs
puisqu'il avait été relevé jacob
desvarieux du groupe kassav qu'il se
marie avec sakho sa collègue jusqu'à une
bureau elle est bon je serai le 11 mai
en fait le 11 mai c'est la date d'un
concert très important paris a donc
c'était un indice là quand même c'était
c'est un poisson d'avril mais c'est plus
tard c'est qu'après quelques secondes
que je me suis rendu compte qu'il de la
chose bouchra vous vous traquer les
nouvelles les mauvaises afin de fausses
nouvelles sur le web ce pas évident de
pouvoir faire ce travail-là commerce
vous possédez ce que vous avez de
méthodologie particulière pour essayer
de détecter ces fausses choses qui
circulent dans le cyberespace
mais il y en a énormément donc on ne
peut pas tout traquer tout vérifier et
puis comme vous l'avez dit à plusieurs
niveaux il ya la désinformation qui est
vraiment mal intentionnés l essai
parisien et parodique et les poissons
d'avril c'est comme si un peu maintenant
le phénomène ce poisson d'avril qui
arrivait une fois par année arrive tout
le temps
à tous les jours il ya passé les rumeurs
légende urbaine qui existait avant les
réseaux sociaux de demain il se passe
quelque chose une catastrophe un
changement dans la société
les voisins si parlement c'est le
téléphone arabe donc la maintenance
qu'il existait depuis des siècles
devient encore plus présent sur les
réseaux sociaux non qu'ils aient toutes
sortes de niveau de fausses nouvelles et
des informations
et puis à ce qu'on regarde long que moi
et mon collègue jack fisk qui était dans
le extrait du reportage d' enquête
on va voir premièrement à quel point ça
circule et donc des fois il ya des
forces nouvelles ont tellement il ya
quelques personnes quelques dizaines de
personnes qui l'ont vu est ce que ça
vaut la peine parce qu'à partir du
moment où radio-canada en fait un
article là il ya des milliers de
personnes qui le voient en pie des fois
c'est des fous des forces nouvelles qui
seront créées dans le but de de taper
sur un groupe dans le but de de créer de
la peur on pense différemment notre en
fait c'est à dire toujours une intention
derrière
oui c'est ça donc surtout quand c'est
créé intentionnellement donc des fois
c'est une déformation donc un peu qu'ils
aient pas intentionnel puis ce qu'on
appelle le téléphone arabe mais défaut
ci crée vraiment des gens qui n'aiment
pas les réfugiés qui ont par des
réfugiés donc qu'ils vont créer des
articles en disant regardez les dangers
que ça amène ce phénomène là donc là
parfois on se dit si a pas beaucoup de
gens qui ont vu cette forces nouvelles
qui est parfois de la propagande
même en faisant un article radio-canada
pour dire que c'est faux est-ce qu'on
contribue à amplifier ce ne sera pas
gagné donc premier critère c'est est-ce
que ça a vraiment circuler beaucoup dans
la société suffisamment pour qu'on se
dise ya tellement de gens qui l'ont vu
qu'on doit rectifier les faits et puis
après il ya les conséquences la porter
dans parfois c'est des poissons d'avril
des choses que beaucoup de gens ont vu
mais qui sont un peu insolite un peu
cocasse et tandis que d'autres forces
nouvelles où c'est vraiment des gens
reçoivent des menaces et considère
seulement dans la vraie vie
une hausse de seulement qu'on se dit bon
moment est-ce que donc ça et beaucoup
d'impact et est-ce que ça a des
conséquences graves que les gens croient
à ça et donc c'est là qu'ont choisi est
ce que ça vaut la peine d'enquêté
là-dessus d'en faire un article
puis après ça il ya une méthodologie
pour vérifier si c'est vraiment pas fort
on sait tout de suite si évident que
c'est faux parce que la source est un
site de forces nouvelles parfois on
n'est pas certain donc là on va essayer
de voir si c'est une photo d'où vient
cette photo là est-ce qu'elle a été
utilisé dans d'autres contextes que
cette photo là est ce que la légende
disent que c'est vraiment le lieu
l'endroit la date que ça représente et
puis apprécié de voir qui si par exemple
dit souvent ça va être justin trudeau a
dit telle chose donc ça va être de voir
ce qu'ont à la source est ce qu'on a un
enregistrement où il me dit où est ce
que c'est une citation à inventer donc
voilà et toutes sortes des tables de
vérifications à faire parce qu'on veut
évidemment quand on dit qu'une nouvelle
fosses on veut pas nous mêmes faire des
erreurs bien sûr en rajoute au super
pascal dans le monde des sciences
est ce que ces cures ans à la
circulation de fausses nouvelles
c'est non seulement courant mais les
petits bonheurs des statistiques des
gens vont vous dire que tout ce qui
touche à la santé serait le deuxième où
la première source de nouvelles fausses
nouvelles les plus fréquents on y pense
que vous entrez dans santé si vous
entrez sens l'alimentation de la santé
c'est certain que c'est le plus le plus
grand nombre de forces nouvelles qui
circulent sont là en dehors de la
première perte de poids
n'importe qui n'importe quel produit ce
que vous guérir de n'importe quoi
le tout en même temps alors forcément il
ya beaucoup de choses là dedans alors
faut bien comprendre que ce qu'on fait
que les décideurs de rumeurs c'est pas
de prendre une obscure recherche en
astrophysique et d'aller dire avant le
septième paragraphe la donne y x ou y on
prend des nouvelles touches le commun
des mortels des choses qui nous tous
socialement économiquement politiquement
et on essaie de retourner la source
une des choses une des questions qu'on
doit toujours se poser donc quand on est
devant le produit miracle irrite ou bien
est ce qu'une étude quelque part est ce
que quelqu'un a fait l'étude là dessus
ici elle est possible dans l'article
original ou dans le post facebook
original
on essaie de voir en fait des recherches
dans les bars de nuit pour voir est ce
que des chercheurs qui sont déjà penchés
là dessus et ça arrive qu'on arrive à
des résultats mitigés à savoir bon c'est
pas entièrement faux il ya une partie de
l'affirmation qui est vrai ou encore on
le sait pas et l'on fait un article doit
être du type
les trois ou quatre ou cinq choses qu'il
faut savoir sur ce produit là où sur
cette maladie là alors c'est toujours
c'est souvent plus nuancé les
vérifications des faits en sciences
parce que la science a cette
caractéristique de pas toujours est
tranchée justement elle avance à petits
pas prude main mais là où on est
vraiment dans l'évidence dans la réponse
tranchée c'est quand on lui doit une
affirmation ridicule comme de le succès
des républiques le cancer
dans quel cas les indices parfois la
france a l'air trop les salaires est
vraisemblable on se dit quand même cet
indice sera attiré votre attention cette
résiste pour attire notre attention mais
défend le des surprises on peut se
rencontrent a effectivement il est aisé
qui ont été faites là dessus c'est ce
sont des trucs ou d'aider des trucs
qu'on est là avec l'expérience et comme
disait tantôt bail est certaine ces
trucs là qu'on peut transmettre au grand
public un des messages qu'on aime bien
transmettre si c'est pas parce que vous
n'avez pas éclusiers ans hier ce que
parce que cette pause scientifique que
vous peut pas vous même et s'est trouvé
quelques uns disent dans l'axé qui
devrait vous faire douter ce qui est pas
quelque part aussi auprès des gens qui
reçoivent des messages disant que
attention cette nouvelle réforme c'est
aussi pourquoi un blocage ou non je veux
y croire cette nouvelle et ça aussi
c'est quelque chose qui est très
difficile comme chef et puis ça aussi on
le voit en sciences mais on le voit dans
les nouvelles politiques parce que on a
tous des billets on a des préférences et
on a des idées préconçues
je pense qu on est notre pire ennemi
quelqu'un qui par exemple dont un mode
de vie très naturel qui mangent bio qui
mange léger de rien va être plus
susceptibles de croire des articles qui
disent que le jus de céleri peut guérir
le cancer pas forcément mais parfois
justement il va avoir peut-être la
difficulté à accepter des nouvelles qui
vont contre son mode de vie ils vont
être plus susceptibles de croire des
nouvelles qui confirme son mode de vie
même si ce qui le conforte dans ses
opinions et peut-être faux et ce qu'ils
déstabilisent est peut-être vrai ou
pareillement des gens qui sont empressés
cauchy sont ses seuls républicains aux
états unis vont être plus enclins à
croire des nouvelles qui confirment que
leur parti raison et qui qui disent
qu'elle
les partis opposés à tort mais c'est ça
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut vraiment
laissé ses idées préconçues deux côtés
se dire même si on vote pour tel parti
politique peut-être que telle nouvelle
qui dit que notre parti pour lequel on
vote s'est trompé peut-être cette
nouvelle loi est elle est vraie et puis
souvent c'est ça en sciences et en santé
on veut par facilité simplifier les
choses devant les compagnies
pharmaceutiques sont tout comme intérêt
principal leurs intérêts financiers les
ogm donc c'est m'avait donc c'est pas
tout et pas aussi tranchée que parfois
les l'immédiat ont tendance à vouloir
faire des articles sont un peu simples
sont peu rapide dont on voit une étude
qui dit que le chocolat riz du risque de
cancer c'est tentant d'en faire un
accessoire temps d'en faire un article
sympa ce que peut-être que ça parle d'
une véritable étude menée en france on
compte que l'étude a utilisé un composé
chimique sur des souris puis finalement
cette étude là est livrée mais la faire
un raccourci que dire le jeu kohler et
du risque de ce cancer c'est un
raccourci beaucoup trop gros donc pas
forcément une force nouvelle mais c'est
un média qui a voulu être faire un
article un peu trop simplifié et exagéré
de quelque chose qui au départ était
vrai je me permets dit oui je dirai ce
que je viens de bulles de toutes petites
choses que dans ce petit univers des
gens d'heuliez vérificateur de faire don
éléments ont fait partie et du milieu
deux choses deux petites choses qu'on a
apprise l'une d'entre elles étant
d'essayer de ne pas confronter le
lecteur par une affirmation doit faire
décrocher tout de suite donc
effectivement si on dit c'est fou tu
crois que j'utilise un gearing cancer
dont viennent pas tous les lecteurs y
croyait mais l'autre chose qu'on
commence à découvrir ses segmentés le
plus possible les sujets autant que de
s'attaquer au cancer en général sa tête
il ya un peu de sujet un segment qu'ont
pu vérifier
peut-être la toute dernière étude qui
vient de sortir et que feinte à bord
pour réussir pour être accrochés des
gens qui croient mikko est prêt à
admettre au kit c'est vrai que cette
étude leur le bon sens je vais en ligne
le site est il si on fait ça on a
peut-être avancer un peu dans la bonne
direction
alors voilà justement dans cette
bataille contre les fausses nouvelles
les grands les géants du web sont
souvent montrés du doigt google facebook
et consorts est justement google a
annoncé il ya quelques heures enfin
quelques jours une aide d'un million de
dollars qui va être content qu'il ait
accordé aux la fondation canadienne du
journalisme et cette fausse est cet
argent-là devrait servir entre autres
choses a justement lutter contre les
fausses nouvelles jeu pour justement
morte la conversation vous je vous
propose d'écouter quelqu'un vous
connaissez tous autour de la table
michel cormier qui était directeur de
l'information à radio canada
michel cormier bonjour bonjour michel
vous êtes membre du conseil
d'administration de la fondation pour le
journalisme canadien et surtout ancien
directeur général de l'information des
services français de radio-canada
d'abord michel c'est quoi cette
fondation pour le journalisme canadien
est un organisme à but non lucratif qui
fait de l'éducation sur le journalisme
de la recherche
la présentation si on veut pour pour
améliorer la qualité du journaliste est
aussi pour améliorer un petit peu la
conscience enfin d'aidé désormais du
journalisme auprès de la population
alors on donne des bourses à des jeunes
journalistes ont fait d'aider ont fait
des symposiums régulièrement sur les
enjeux contemporains de journalisme et
je vois des forces nouvelles ou du port
un disque de guerre ou la question
financière du journalisme depuis les
enjeux qui sont son intérêt on fait
régulièrement des conférences pour
attirer le public qu'on réfléchisse
ensemble socialistes question et tout le
monde y ait accès c'est à dire que ce
sont les journalistes ou le grand public
alors c'est ouvert au grand public qu'on
a fait on a fait un événement au mois de
février
royal justement ready canada où on le
met le directeur général des élections
du canada les journalistes de l'agencé
france presse qui est spécialiste dans
la vérification des faits et on a fait
une soirée de discussion animée par anne
avec des choses sur la question des
fausses nouvelles et des élections
fédérales qui sont menées d'un auteur on
est toujours dans le contemporain sont
très bien alors maintenant donc google
news initiative dont qui relève de
l'agrégateur de nouvelles et moteur de
recherche google docs 3,1 millions de
dollars là
fondation à quoi va servir cet argent
est exactement passé d'argent disponible
pour les rédactions des griffes des
médias à la fois en région ou en région
métropolitaine les grands objets petit
média pour soi faire du journalisme
autour de la question des fausses
nouvelles ou soit faire de la formation
enfin de ce qu'on appelle de la
littératie des campagnes d'éducation
populaire pour aider les gens se
trouvaient dans cet univers là parce
qu'on sait que c'est assez facile de se
séparer
alors ce ce montant s'ajoute a déjà un
bon sens et vous vous la tenez à travers
la fondation et le l'organisme civique
qui fait d'éducation populaire auprès
des jeunes des élèves dans les écoles il
ya déjà trois ou quatre ans qu'on
travaille avec google la fondation sur
ce genre d'initiative va alors
l'initiative qui était limité aux écoles
et au secondaire maintenant être si on
veut propager à la population que
général salaire de contributions
ponctuelles mais qui reviennent est-ce
que vous avez l'impression cette
collaboration risque de durer un certain
moment quand même je crois voir une
relation quand même ch et développer
votre google
alors on a des liens quand même régulier
je pense que nos gosses j'ai très bien
des enjeux de des fausses nouvelles il
cherche à contribuer de la façon la plus
efficace possible alors de passer à
travers une fondation comme la nôtre ça
permet aussi de thé pour nous de gérer
un peu cet argent là dans les meilleurs
intérêts du khalife pour l'instant
d'autres subventions va servir à
développer ou à rendre disponibles des
outils sur le web les fausses nouvelles
missions londres on le sait sont aussi
diffusées par les médias conventionnels
qui ne sont pas nécessairement sur le
web
et qu'est ce qu'on fait pour cette
catégorie c'est la grande question
l'époque pour le journalisme est certain
que on en revient à la base vérifier
l'information du poids plutôt qu'une il
ya quand même maintenant toutes sortes
d'outils aussi que sont disponibles pas
d'essai pour vérifier par exemple la
véracité des photos et même des
programmes spécialisés qui peuvent nous
permettre de faire ça alors c'est pour
les médias de se servir de tous
ces instruments là et aussi on voit bien
que toute la question de la vérification
des faits est devenu maintenant une
partie importante de vannerie ce qui se
pratique un peu partout alors
alors si c'est pas magique ça ça bloque
pas tout mais de s'assurer qu'on fait de
l'information crédible mix'n auraient de
l'information vérifiée et qu'on est
transparent avec nos méthodes de travail
je pense que ça peut aider à donner
confiance au public d'un journaliste
professionnel
quand vous observez ici chez nous on va
dire eu au québec au canada
radio canada may parlant pas parce que
vous avez quand même été l'un des
acteurs qui ont contribué à ce que les
choses parce qu'on va se font en ce
moment est-ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'ils se soucient aussi chez d'autres
confrères dans d'autres organes et que
le mouvement semble plus généralisé ou
c'est juste quelques acteurs qui essaie
de se battre contre ce fléau et je pense
que tout le monde tout le monde est
conscient de sa fédération
c'est beaucoup de travail même dans les
écoles et dans les villages les
communautés pour justement combattre des
fausses nouvelles
si la journée internationale de la
presse en fin vendredi
et donc il ya aussi d'autres sortes
d'activités autour de 2 autour de cela
nous la fondation s'est joint la fpjq
peau demandé aux médias d'ouvrir leurs
portes au public
alors donc il ya une grande journée
portes ouvertes où les gens peuvent
venir discuter des journalistes comment
ils font le métier de disc y était
question là aussi des fausses nouvelles
pour voir comment y échapper
alors je pense qu'il ya une crise de
confiance qui est non généralisée
partout maintenant c'est d'avoir des
moyens de pouvoir combattre ce trio là
et on sait très bien aussi que les
médias souffrent financièrement alors de
faire se raccorde là ce soir
pas facile donc l'argent c'est le nerf
de la guerre dans cette bataille bon
c'est quand même une partie importante
de l'arsenal mais c'est une bataille qui
est gagnable
je pense que oui on sait si on regarde
un petit peu les les chiffres bon c'est
sûr qu'on sent que il ya une plus grande
confiance maintenant vers des
journalistes il ya quelques années on
était vraiment dans le fond de la carte
si on veut alors là on sent que les gens
maintenant
après avoir traversé une époque où tout
le monde se disait journalistes ou
l'information circulait sans qu'elles
soient identifiés dont 120 ans les gens
reviennent à des sources d'informations
crédibles vérifier s'ils veulent
s'informer alors moi je suis très
optimiste pour l'avenir
voilà musicaux mais je rappelle que vous
êtes membre du conseil d'administration
de la fondation pour le journalisme
canadien et surtout ancien directeur
général de l'information des services
français de radio-canada merci beaucoup
michel bienvenu alors pascal voile
agence science-presse vous avez fait
allusion à votre rubrique sur les
détecteurs de rumeurs et sans même me
pose la question est ce que parce que
vous êtes km ans danseuse dans ce
travail là depuis quelques temps est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que cette
bataille contre les fausses nouvelles et
gagnable ou à tout le moins qu on peut
faire des avancées significatives
on peut répondre de niveau 1 niveau il
retourne est aujourd hui les forces
nouvelles y en aura toujours je pense
que si on pouvait s voyager dans le
temps et rencontrer les entreprises
trédias sans bilan il sera contée
problement des histoires
invraisemblables au coin du feu
par contre on est dans un univers
effectivement de réseaux sociaux où
n'importe qui peut produire
l'information et où tout est pareil tout
arrive sur facebook
indissociable du canada où mon blog
moi.com sont présentés la même façon et
ça sur ce point là et des batailles
qu'on peut gagner on peut apprendre
petit à petit aux gens à développer le
réflexe de vérifier la source et à
développer aussi le réflexe tout bec de
lire un texte avant de le partager
j'ai pas si vous savez qu'il ya une
statistique qui dit qu' au moins 50% des
nouvelles qui sont partagés n'ont pas
été élues moisi on sait que la personne
a cliqué sur je partage il ne sait même
pas ce que la partager en juin beauté
une belle photo alors bien sûr
heureusement dans l'ue surtout de vraies
nouvelles mais c'est aussi la façon dont
une attaque est fausse nouvelle se
propage alors si on peut amener le
public à développer ce genre de réflexe
la de base des gens vont commencer à
faire un ménage dont les forces
nouvelles
alors un dernier point il nous reste
quelques petites minutes bon aujourd'hui
quand même je le disais en introduction
c'est la journée internationale de la
liberté de la presse
c'est une journée qui a pour thème les
élections le rôle de rôle des médias
dans les élections
est ce que dans un contexte de notre
québec canada
est ce que cette journée là une certaine
pertinence l'année de liberté de la
presse selon vous vous posez les
questions des journalistes bien sûr
c'est fait et c'est une bataille ça
aussi c'est une bataille qui un certain
niveau sera jamais entièrement gagné
quand on regarde les normes scepticisme
qu'une passer la population au face aux
médias
la dévalorisation des médias aux yeux
d'une partie la population c'est
doublement important dans un pays comme
le canada de défendre ce parce que c'est
pas je pars avant le 2 septembre
l'importance d'un médium on est
conscient qu'il faut qu'on développe des
stratégies des trucs pour convaincre les
gens pour leur faire comprendre pourquoi
c'est important les médias et on en
revient encore à l'action les fausses
nouvelles
c'est pas à leur marteler à fait
confiance aux médiocres comme par magie
vont joindre la direction
mais si on les a mal paru même à faire
cette démarche de vérification bateau
tard et qu'on se rencontre à b ou de
nouvelles de radio-canada il est quand
même plus fiables que la nouvelle de mon
blog à nos points quand tu te fais
quelques secondes manel je pense que le
contexte est presque similaire dans tous
les domaines pas uniquement avec les
médias parce que il y a eu avec
l'avènement des nouvelles technologies
une démocratisation de l'accès à
l'information
du coup tout le monde est devenu
architecte tout le monde est devenu
médecin tout le monde c'est à dire on
trouve des forums où les gens disent
j'ai tel rougeurs il publie sa photo il
se demande quel est le diagnostic
donc je pense que les professionnels de
tous les corps de métiers se bat
aujourd'hui pour avoir encore leur
crédibilité et leur mot à dire dans leur
domaine comme le journalisme comme dans
tout autre domaine parce que cette
démocrate démocratisation de l'accès à
l'information a rendu tout le monde pro
dont je n'entends pas les experts
banquiers oui voila merci merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup
manel jamais je répète des architectes
futur humaniste en tout cas vous êtes
aussi chargé de cours à l'université de
l'université de montréal
je travaille pour la compagnie d'infra
planification urbaine dans le processus
de rétablissement des inondations à la
ville de rigaud qu'on voit la cerise
avant le week-end j'ai des enfants
pascal lapointe de rédacteur en chef de
l'agencé science presse il y avait aussi
avec nous bouchra wathiq qui a dû partir
et puis raymond des marteaux de radio
canada international qui est un habitué
de l'émission il sut l'idiot utile et je
vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous et on s'est dit à bientôt
[Musique]